i would never want you to do that
thank god
the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show is brought to you by me undies
mandy's are seriously soft feel good
undies delivered right to your door
and the best part
is mandy's is offering our listeners
20 off of your first pair when you go to
meundies.com joey that's me undies dot
com slash joey and guess what when you
love me undies because you're going to
love them they offer you a subscription
service that gets them sent to your door
automatically so go to meundies.com
joey
show is also brought to you by mvmt
watches movement watches
they start at just 95
and when you go to a department store
you're looking at a 400 to 500 price
range so you're already saving money go
to mvmt mvmtwatches.com
church right now to get 15 off of your
movement watch today i have the black on
black i love it quit it
mvmtwatches.com
church today to get 15 off
oh [ __ ] it's still black history month
[ __ ]
and this is as black and beautiful as it
gets
a little chaka khan featuring rufus
or the other way around does it [ __ ]
matter
monday february 27th
the church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
here we go [ __ ] here we go
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
monday or tuesday in your world
february 28th the month
[ __ ] flu i forgot it was black
history month that's how [ __ ] fast it
was i think that's why they even do it
that so you don't have that much time to
even [ __ ] jump up and down for the
brothers
thank god we had danny brown on and you
know
i'm always trying to reach out to
different diversities and
females and whatever the [ __ ]
available out there what's happening my
brother
yeah [ __ ] danny brown was great i
love daniel it's uh
there's there's a lot of negatives to
technology but it's it makes it
harder to like hate people like you're
not we're not racist but
if you're doing a podcast and you sho
you get a guess they're like they're
black or maybe they're half whatever
they have mexican
there's no way to hate there's no racism
in podcast that's the good thing there's
no racism in [ __ ] podcasts i had a
good time in minneapolis [ __ ] yeah if
you came to any of the shows thank you
very much for coming on supporting this
uh
my sets were kind of rusty some of the
people were laughing some of them
weren't i just blew right past them
i got to work a little harder and uh
that's that but if you came for the
shows i loved you a lot of good people
came out to the shows
brandy lynn came i didn't get to see i
was back there
talking with the owner giving me a
[ __ ] earbud it was a cool dude rick
bronson the mall of america is [ __ ]
great i i really enjoy it
it's a lot of walking i know for a fact
i lost weight
i didn't eat any of the [ __ ] food the
only thing i ate in there was burgers
bagels with turkey on it and uh
lego land i was gonna go in there but
you could smell the [ __ ] flu
you could smell it there's kids
everywhere in there [ __ ]
that's the only problem even if you go
early
you gotta take a flu shot and wear a
scarf you got to walk around in there
like a japanese at an airport with a
mask over your [ __ ] mouth because
you're definitely going to get sick do
you bring medicine i got everything yeah
i bring [ __ ] every
i have everything i have for every
ailment i've ever had
i carry some of it on the plane that's
immediate no spray
the tylenols the other one anxiety
medication a vapor pen i'm prepared and
then in the room and the big in my
travel bag
is where i have my ear drops and [ __ ]
like that then i have another bag
and then there i have like like
pieces for the sleep apnea machine
sugar for coffee blue packages of coffee
a lighter rolling papers it's all back
up so anytime i go to the store before i
travel i get two of each and i stuck it
in there if anything ever happens i got
rolling papers in the sleep apnea
machine
i got a lighter hidden in the sleep
apnea machine just in case we're on an
island who's gonna [ __ ] live at least
i got two days of clarity by smoking
until [ __ ] i gotta start eating rocks
and [ __ ]
do you have you ever been sick like full
on like a flu yes at a gig yeah oh no i
had uh in chicago last year two years
ago in rosewood where i taped the
special i had yeah that was the worst
ever i had that [ __ ] of uh vertigo
vertigo oh no yeah it was [ __ ]
horrible i could have canceled but i
didn't on a saturday night
i remember walking to the in the airport
the next day
and thinking that i was i felt like i
was gonna die i had to walk a certain
way
because every time i stepped out of it
the place would spin that's scary my
actually one of the maddest times i've
ever been at my mother was she got
vertigo and fell down and they called an
ambulance like they had to bring an
ambulance no no it's horrible i made it
through the show
i laid down all day i didn't make any
unnecessary movements
it was something to do with my ears and
swimming so i tried to drain my ears
drained my ears drained my ears
q-tip them and then i did the best i
could on stage if i'd go a certain way i
couldn't be very animated
uh it's a [ __ ] to get sick when
you have to do comedy and i've seen
people work through it man it's like
anything else
you know it's like anything else it's
not even the sickness what about the
personal issues what about if you're
going through a divorce what about if
someone in your family dies what about
somebody if your family is ill
you still got to turn it on for that
hour you know one of the biggest lessons
i learned
i think one of the things that made me
that
that toughened me up the most
was when i forced myself
to do a set after i drop off my daughter
jack
when i drop her off on wednesdays
i can never describe to you people at
home how bad i felt
because i always it always felt like it
was the last time i was gonna see her
and i would go home the first couple
weeks i would go home and get upset and
get angry and [ __ ] puke from the
anger
you know you have to [ __ ] when you
get that headache and your blood
pressure rises
i'd or my blood pressure would drop i'd
puke and then i figured it out after
like three weeks i said
the only way i'm gonna get good at
comedy and the only way i'm going to
overcome this pain
is by forcing myself to do comedy
after i drop her off immediately
so there was just one room that started
at 8 on wednesdays thank god for andy
payton
and i would drop her off at seven at the
safeway and right from the safeway
i would force myself to this [ __ ]
comedy room with six people
and i would probably cry halfway there
and then the other half where i'd be
okay i'd always had a joint and a
hashtag
and that you know
that's mental toughness when you have to
go on stage with that pain you know you
know in the beginning
of comedy you have to go on stage and
this month you don't pay the rent
how can you crack jokes when you're
about to get thrown the [ __ ] out
when you can't pay your car insurance
but this is all part of the toughness
this is all i watched a very interesting
movie this weekend what's that
it wasn't the academy award winner but
it let me know
that in some
instances my
or a way of thinking that i was
instilled as a young man still works
i watched the movie the accountant that
was really good i watched it on the
plane because
you're on a [ __ ] plane you know i
have my ipod i'm high
and the account was about ben stiller
and
ben affleck and he kills a bunch of
people and that's that's the subplot of
it that's the
the main thing but the subplot is about
a child
who suffers from severe autism when he
was a young man he suffered from severe
autism he he still started he he has it
he has yeah so
it was kind of weird how he uh
his father was a an army guy
and he didn't want him to be
pampered so he made him force
it on him and there's one scene where
they show him fighting a chinese guy
or a vietnamese guy or an asian guy
whatever i don't want to be whatever
and he [ __ ] he's beating these kids
you know they're beating him but he's
beating these kids there's a man beating
two kids
and finally he turns around looks at the
fall and he goes enough
tomorrow's another day and the father
goes no
to see what you got you gotta peel
leia's back every once in a while and he
goes i gotta know my son's limitations i
almost cried on the [ __ ] plane
because america doesn't think like that
no more america is not even close to
thinking like that anymore
and in my mind still
you know i hate [ __ ] needles but
thursday i'm driving to marina del rey
the drive i hate the most in the world
on the 405
to force myself against this fear
you know i'm not looking to be the
greatest jujitsu guy in the [ __ ]
world
not at all i go there because every time
i go that's a struggle it's hard for me
to breathe i panic
so
people don't do
people in this country anymore not doing
this stuff with their kids i've had
parents tell me that their kids had
severe cases of add let me tell you
something i think about my childhood and
i had a dd like a [ __ ] and saw a
lot of people around them and it went
untreated because nobody knew what it
was then
and you know what people dealt with it
people found something to deal with i'm
gonna tell you something that you're
gonna [ __ ] turn this podcast off when
i'm gonna tell you
but i'm gonna tell you that it's very
true
do you know for years
from the years of 87 to 91
or 92
this is embarrassing to say every time i
did cocaine once i got to a certain
level of highness
i would do math for hours
what do you mean like like i would buy a
math workbook that had algebra and
what's the one after algebra geometry
geometry
and i [ __ ] would do the workbooks for
two three hours at a time while i was
doing a ball of coke what as [ __ ]
and i'm embarrassed to say this
it started in 86 and i would sit there
for hours
and do what if things
what if i had 40 kilos of blow
and i'd cut each kilo with
four ounces which would give me a kilo
is what 32.2 ounces i mean had you're
doing drug word problems i would do drug
work problems
for four or five hours until i got so
bored i did everything and i try to
break down how much steve grebo would
sell
to make six million dollars so that's
reverse algebra
do you understand me i would [ __ ] do
that for hours what would steve grabo
have to sell
to pick up six million dollars every six
weeks
that one took me like [ __ ] two months
but i figured it out on my own after he
got caught i did i do all that
and and you think back to it now
i can never do math like that now but
all i was doing
was giving myself what's the pill people
take today the speed
focus
yes
it was a different part it was a
different
thing of adderall if you really think
about it cocaine worked in my mind
like an adderall why do you look at
shadows so much when you're on cocaine
why do you focus on the [ __ ] people
for hours
why do you look under the front step of
your door when you're on cocaine how can
you do that for six hours
and you focus and you see shadows and
[ __ ] your mind plays tricks on you how
because that speed
it's kind of weird to say and again i i
hope you people don't turn the podcast
off when you hear me say this
when i stop snorting coke
90 days later my eyesight went to [ __ ]
i wish that was a joke how's your math
your math is still good my math is solid
but i can't do what i was doing in 87
for four or five years what i'm doing
now and you didn't get a calculator
not even close
i wouldn't [ __ ] buy a calculator if
you paid me why because i'm still a mad
dude i still do everything by hand
have you made like a terrible mistake
yet
uh
i correct you know because of my add
i do the thing four or five times
so do you understand i don't take add
medication but in this movie
this the father recognized the kid had a
problem and instead of pampering them
and putting them in a school where
everybody hugs each other and nothing
gets solved you know the kid would force
himself every day
to play loud music and play like a flash
strobe light for 10 minutes and at the
end of the 10 minutes in this movie the
character would eat uh whatever they
take whatever somebody with that disease
or that whatever they call that takes
right and it's great because he he would
do more things like he would rub his
muscles
like he uh and i don't know like what do
you think like do you think he became
like sort of a criminal because of all
that no no no no you know the autism
that he had
just caused an extreme that's just you
know the autism made him a great
accountant the autism made him a great
accountant and
you know i never knew until about two
years ago how smart those autism is what
a weird thing is oh yeah have you seen
the one there's a weird thing it's just
a weird spectrum of there's just one guy
that i've seen where and who knows it
could be fake but it's like
it says that they took this autistic man
on a helicopter ride around new york
city and he drew in pen
the entire skyline with like every
building from memory
it's like they they may not have i don't
really know that deep into it but a lot
of them have like they might lack
socially but they're just so
they're like
next level smart like smart that we
don't even understand
all right so you know guys you go on the
road when you write you know like i've
said a thousand times i always write
for 10 to 12 years i would sit there i
was taught to write you sit there like
three [ __ ] idiots and you chew on
your pen and you throw down stuff it
became so [ __ ]
bad for me that i stopped doing it
completely and that's why
nothing was really going on in my life
nothing really really started for me
until i started going on myspace every
monday and writing a blog
and even though the blog was misspelled
or whatever
just doing working that muscle every
monday i would take a notebook and lay
that next to me and while i was working
that story i would think a three or four
other stories it would exercise
my muscles you know when you work your
biceps and you're doing curls
yeah it the primary muscle of the
[ __ ] curl is your bicep but the
secondary muscles are your forearms and
your you know your shoulder has three
heads no front head of your shoulders
and
it's just really interesting [ __ ] and
the same thing happens with writing
one of the things that got me
there was two books that really stood
out in my mind
the one book was on writing by stephen
king and i had read at this point
i am i'm not gonna lie to nobody
i did what everybody else does in l.a
l.a has a scam
la has a scam that when you move here
uh lee came here to be a
editor and one day he goes joey you know
what
my minor was writing so i'm going to
start writing so
what will we do lee's either going to
have a good friend that's a writer
because birds of a feather flock
together or
lee's going to go to samuel french
like every other [ __ ] sucker
including myself and buy 2 000 books on
writing
because we feel that if we write if we
read half the book
we're going to learn how to write and
guys i threw away thousands
thousands on books and i got to be
honest i read every single one of them
but you know how much i did from reading
those books not one thing that they told
me to do jean parade when i first
started who was bob hope's writer it's a
great book to read but you're going to
read jokes and you're going to go joey
what the [ __ ]
did this guy write in electricity or did
he write in a candle because they're old
style jokes you know but he teaches you
the basics
of writing a joke that was the only
workbook i ever ever did and i did do
the judy carter workbook
i could be wrong but i think you're way
ahead of more people just be just even
reading the books i have a ton of books
like whenever i get involved in
something i'll buy two or three books
like the last thing i bought was three
blackjack books i've had them for a week
and i've cracked like one for like three
minutes i don't know i think a lot of
people buy those books and they don't
even ever even open them when i went to
prison i realized the importance of
reading
i knew how to read
i learned how to read
i had a teacher in the seventh grade mr
king mo the guy that left me back
he made you read a book a month
and do oral book reports oh [ __ ] and i
really learned a lot about myself
because i learned how bad my
comprehension was
and that's add i learned how bad i could
read a whole chapter and then you could
say joy what's the chapter button go ah
so i would have to read everything twice
till today i read everything twice
as i'm reading it it's it's impos i
won't retain anything if i don't
i even have to make notes sometimes
when i read a good book once i'm on page
15 or 20 and this book's got me
whether it's a jimmy page book which i
cool i started the other day and then i
i didn't take it on the [ __ ] plane
because i knew
i'm gonna get hooked on this [ __ ]
thing
la lingas [ __ ]
get me a book that's gonna get me hooked
like heroin and it's two [ __ ] days of
reading up all night and that's what
would happen to me
in prison
well in prison i started reading and
my one of my good buddies in there was a
librarian and he he found the books that
i liked
you know in prison was where i
discovered cujoho and i discovered
that's a scary i haven't even i
discovered uh on wings of eagles the
ross perot story i discovered snow blind
by zachary swann
another good book about smuggling this
guy was smuggling in the 60s i
discovered a book you know
just just this guy you turned me you
know books on music it was endless it
was endless and and the book club was us
in prison talking about the book when i
brought it back
he would give me the book i'd read it
and then i'd come back
and it was him and a black guy that were
always in the library and they read
everything and they kind of read the
same
guess what else i read in prison what
goodfellas
way before the movie way before the
movie
i read goodfellas in prison and during
while i was reading their book
they did an interview on henry hill in
2020.
so i was reading top-notch books in
prison
i read like the you know um
i read a little bit about you know
because i had a lot of black friends in
there so i read a little bit about not
martin luther king but minister
farrakhan
i read a lot of different stuff
obviously prison is terrible
but if you're like like if you were
lucky you went through high school but
if there if there's people in prison who
didn't get to go to school for whatever
reason can you go to prison and get an
education yes really that's cool yes
yes you go to prison if you really
really really want to
learn and they have it available to you
there's inmates that are solid guys man
and just because
they made a mistake
some mistakes were worse than others
some weren't thought out
because of the crime i did and the
points i had and the situation i had
wanted to when i got it i went into a
place where it was people getting out
soon they had two or three years left
and these guys had already done their
hard time and i got to talk to them and
they explained different things to me
you know
um
and i listened
i listened i learned a lot and i learned
a lot about human nature
i learned about what i didn't want to do
in my life
the things i did not want to do
i looked at i would look at 10 inmates
and look at seven of them that all had
the same habits
i shied away from all those [ __ ]
habits
you know did you did you see
those habits in yourself at that point
absolutely
absolutely listen like two years before
i got a ninth i got arrested in 1987.
and in 1984 i knew i was going to get
arrested
it was just a matter of time i was just
walking around
in 1985 i was walking around getting
waiting to get arrested or waiting to
get shot
and i was carrying a weapon once i went
to colorado the weapon stayed
and i became a different person it was
like i was a [ __ ] uh
person who would change and then after a
few months i went back to who i was a
[ __ ] thief
and credit card you know it was like it
was like a [ __ ] pattern
but i always you know during that whole
time i was taking classes
even during when i lived in snowmass
and i was doing all the [ __ ] i was doing
up there i was at colorado mountain
college
i was always one of those guys that had
a little bit of hope
that had a little bit of hope i didn't
think i could become anything
but i wanted to absorb as much knowledge
as i could that would get me to the next
level that's so crazy to me because you
said that today on your periscope that
you wanted to make something of your
life
and i don't know i i i'm starting to
think that maybe my thinking has been
wrong but ever since i've been a kid
the only like to me
making it means just you have a lot of
money
no no no that's that's what people are
wrong
that's the misconception we have to
we're about 30 because by 30 we meet
people who have a lot of money right
that are living their life wrong and we
meet people who have a lot of money that
i mean they're they're living their life
the wrong way or we admire
there's two ways to live your life how
you have money it's when what part of
your life you get it
if i give
10
21 year olds a million dollars cash
within a year
six of them will be broke at least two
of them would have made investments they
would have bought a pizza place
or bought their parents houses or
something but six of them would have
been gone now i take those same 10
people and give them a million dollars a
piece when they're 10 and the
percentages will go low because they've
worked they've paid off debt i mean like
at 30 10 30 yes i'm sorry at 30 and if i
take those 10
same 10 people at 40
what'll happen the percentages go higher
because we paid our dues it's like a
it's like we goof around but it's true
we're women when they're 20 they want
the hot guy who's got a tattoo and a
beard and you know says all these things
but when they're dirty they lower their
expectations by the time they're 40
they'll marry a guy with a kid
you know because they understand where
life goes it's a
i'm happy i i
accepted prison at that age
it was good that i went at that age
and it was good what i got out of it at
that age
i got all the right things at that age
and listen
like i said a thousand times before i
didn't stop being a [ __ ] criminal
until
15 years ago in one way or another you
know i was still breaking a law whether
i was selling coke or stealing lighters
it's still breaking the [ __ ] law
what do you think would have happened if
you hadn't gone to the prison that you
went to
if you'd gone to like a hardcore
prison
i would have
fought for my life
i would have whatever the situation was
i had a rise for it i knew that mentally
before i went in
i knew that at every level i didn't know
what i was getting myself into
but whatever it was i was prepared you
know i didn't play into the game listen
i could have gone into prison hooked up
with three dudes the first day because
the first day i hooked you know me
though you seem
i got every army i get the best
armenians in town
the first day i got to camp george west
i hooked up with this dude from new york
talking to me and within an hour he had
me hooked up with a shot of heroin in
his room an hour later what do you talk
if i wanted a shot i had one
and then he had a buddy
who i could i've seen this guy before he
was a white dude that kept smiling and
agree with him to everything
and i knew that these two guys were by
the way
i wasn't going to do heroin
i said yeah i'll see you later i got
along like needles and i disappeared
about a day later kid took me aside and
go stay away from those two guys
those two guys are scam artists they
make you send them money and they they
they make their living off when you
shoot heroin
you shoot it
there's a cotton ball
and these guys would make their living
off of that cotton ball like that cotton
ball that last shot of heroin like they
were just
you know regular [ __ ]
things yeah yeah i avoided them that's
it i was still their friend i didn't say
i was at war with them or anything if
they came into the kitchen and you know
i could hook them up with an extra bonus
on my wood
i just didn't go into that [ __ ] feed
i could have gone into any different
group i wanted to and i pretty much
stayed to myself and got away with it
is that like
for i used to watch all those i think
i've watched every lockup and the netgeo
one that they have
and that everything and
all that
i watched that stuff yeah the isolation
stuff and stuff
was pretty much i i never saw that
okay i never saw that isolation so i
could lie to you and tell you i was hard
i was in a hole for three nine hours
when i got in that dog i wanted to do my
time and get the [ __ ] out of that okay
uh i wasn't gonna let myself get bullied
i wouldn't know that [ __ ] was gonna
happen if you smacked me i was gonna
smack you back no matter what size you
were
if you spoke down to me i know a way how
to
talk back to you without
you getting mad
and i never came down to it i fought a
kid in there severino i still love him
with all my heart
and i beat up that white dude for
[ __ ] the dude i put the box of [ __ ]
in this [ __ ] draw
that half a [ __ ] [ __ ] wannabe biker
and that was it that i had no problems
and in the halfway house i really had no
problems
i just knew listen man i was thinking
this weekend in minneapolis about
what's going on right now whether it's
animal planet the podcast
stand-up comedy my family the daughter
you you know
it took 54 years to surround myself
with the right situation
i'm no better than you or whatever
that's why i talk to you the way i do
at the age of 28 because i want you to
eliminate the waste
it's just a lot of waste
and god knows i did
90 of it
in no different way than just doing
stupid [ __ ]
this country if you see the direction
it's going if you're young right now
i want you to strap your seat belts on i
want you to focus
i want you to buy property i want you to
do as much as you can so you have
as much security by the age of 40 who
knows that we're going to have social
security you know when i was a child
they said there wasn't going to be no
social security
you know who knows i'm 54 i'm thinking
about social security i'm not going to
lie to you guys starting next year i
take leader breakfast every day fifteen
percent off at denny's you know what i'm
saying
and he picks up the tip and mcdonald's
you get like a free uh
senior discount
but i i
the thing
you know this morning i said something
lee call me because it's the funniest
thing i said
you know when i i didn't watch the
oscars last night but i watched cnn
later on that night
and i saw what had happened and the
people the hindu made the speech and the
other guy who boycotted it and
you know it's like it's the oscars we're
trying to have a good time and you got
to bring all that [ __ ] up you know
enough
and they do it for what to get the pat
in the back you know i rather [ __ ]
get [ __ ] in the ass by a [ __ ] then
that pat in the back for me being brave
for sticking up to trump it's over you
know i mean what the [ __ ] are you
bitching about still you know
and i was sitting there
thinking about i'm never i never want to
be around those people like since i
moved here guys guys i don't tonight i
was supposed to go to doug benson's
uh high court premiere which starts
tonight by the way and it's a pretty
good show doug did a good job he hey you
smoking pot on tv
you got to take your hat off to the
[ __ ] kids so when i'm i'm on one of
the episodes he's got a great crew
of people that are playing bailiffs i
think uh who else uh jessie may pelosi
jesse peluso's playing one of the bail
is one of our girls
so yeah they got a a great crew so i
wish him all the the luck in the world
and you think about the journey he took
when i think about comedy i don't think
of myself as a good comedian or a great
comedian whether i'm going to be
remembered or you don't see me going on
tours or selling tickets like dane cook
or nothing you know what i like about
that i did
was that
the journey to get to the comedy store
i still can't believe it the talent with
me there's no talent i'm just a fat
[ __ ] guy that grew up on a corner and
knows how to tell a story you know what
i'm saying there's no [ __ ] talent
here the talent was getting me here
like how the [ __ ] did i end up in
california you know what i'm saying like
he went to school for four years we've
had this discussion you've looked me in
the eye and said that school didn't got
for you you could have learned more in
high school hanging out with [ __ ] uh
dudes who are nerds you know
but the journey you made that's where
the talent is that's where the
persistence is
you came out here with a girl who came
out here twice and left
you know since we've been here we've had
people come and [ __ ] go
the talent is getting here
it's not become for me it wasn't i don't
see nothing in the comedy
i like that i do calmly and i'm lucky i
got involved in it
but for me
listen man before my mother died i knew
i was gonna bust out of north berg i
love new jersey i love everything it
stands for but there was something about
north bergen that i know i didn't want
to stay there completely understand what
you're saying
i know there's a lot of people who
understand what i'm saying a lot of
people who don't
and i appreciate a lot of the people who
stayed at home today i did something
weird today
one of my biggest sorrows is the day the
damage i did in the bender household
from 1979 to 1981. it's it's it's
unexcusable
you know thank god bobby talks to me
john talks to me from time to time who
i was supposed to move in with
and yesterday when i got off the plane i
went on facebook last night to post some
videos and i saw that prayers for his
sister
renee and uh
i still remember moving in their house
and my mom died and how
she would cut my hair for free and i
would go over there and she'd goof
around with me and
and
a year and a half later she got a
boyfriend
you know who i knew
and i can't lie to you i kind of got
jealous you know i was a 17 year old kid
she was like my big sister who i had a
crush on and
then she ratted me out about something
and that really destroyed me so i i did
something stupid years later it's not
even worth talking about and
i pissed off the family and then the
father died who
i was just writing about in the book
today how he came up to me at the
funeral at my mother's wake
and said that it would break his heart
if i didn't move in with him you know
this is what i'm the night but before
i'm gonna bury my mother it was just a
weird thing that happened i ended up
moving in with them and then
you know i was just too crazy for john
so when i found out the sister
was in the hospital today i didn't have
the balls to call the hospital i called
her other brother bobby
and they're kind of at war and i
convinced him i convinced him to go to
the hospital and just take her hand
you know
and then i did the impossible i i
facebooked john
because i don't have his number and i
said that i was i would light a candle
for a sister and say a prayer and
i was really sorry for everything i had
done all those years and uh
you know
i want to
go home and talk to him and he said that
he was not mad at me that he was
disappointed with me because
in all the interviews i never mentioned
him or his father you know and i said i
talk about your fault all the time
but i think it's time that i go back
there i go i know your mom hates me
i think it's time that i go back there
and uh
talk to you i want to do something with
you so um
he said absolutely
wow
can you explain
is it like is it like a cousin is it
like a bra like what is john bender to
you
john bender was a kid that i was in the
sixth grade with
when i moved to north bergen in 73 one
of the first people i saw in the
neighborhood was john bender
he was one of those kids that was loud
and obnoxious
and he had a dog and a few he would make
the dog bite you
what he and i thought that was he
thought that was cute
so i avoided him like the [ __ ] plague
okay i just avoided him i would say
hello to him
he had a brother
that i knew and that's it
and the brother was
looking the man
the brother was the man when you were a
kid you know that dude that's the man
he got a car he's he's got the hottest
chick in town right he smokes weed he
listens to cool music his brother was
the man so i was slowly becoming friends
with the brother
because i was tight with carmine
and he was always tight with carmine so
he'd see me always call mine so
he'd accept me for what i was blah blah
blah blah blah
and then one day i transferred from
[ __ ] catholic school got thrown out
and i went to mckinley
and now i had to go to school with john
and all those other kids in that area
and it was not hard for me i can't lie
to you it wasn't hard for me i'm i knew
them already
excuse me i knew half of them
already from the neighborhood so
in the sixth grade i [ __ ] went to the
courts like i did every day and i'm
playing basketball because i want to be
good at basketball okay and this kid
richie ferreira
wants to play basketball so we're
playing basketball and he's kind of
drunk
now i'm [ __ ] 12
you know
maybe 11 12.
richie forever is maybe 17.
so [ __ ] in the middle of the game i
said richie stop following us and he
pushes me he throws the ball down the
[ __ ] hill i get up to push him he
just knocks the [ __ ] out of me
and i i didn't cry and nothing i just
took it and went down to the corner and
went and picked up the [ __ ] ball and
went home but my pants were ripped i
tell the story on stage not in the
extended version
but this all went down and carmine was
on his porch
with peter looking at this this was a
commotion
and the next thing you [ __ ] know i go
home and i go in the shower my mom's
home what the [ __ ] is my mom doing am i
going to shower
the phone always rings if my mom is home
so i don't
but the next day is when when i got home
and she said listen we're gonna go to
the park you got beat up yesterday you
didn't do nothing
and i'm like mom what the [ __ ] is she
taking me to the park she takes the guy
we fight
he beats me up again my mom walks me
home tells me it's okay i'm gonna get
into a lot of brawls in my life
but
guess what richie ferrara does
one he hires john bender to fight me
what
so i'm in the sixth grade one day and
john bender comes and he goes hey [ __ ]
oh spec whatever
we're fighting at three today
you richie ferrara
how how old was john sixth great we're
both the same age
what
both the same age so now i go home i
take my books out now this was big time
this was weird because
they thought
calmly was going to come
so bobby got on the corner they had
people on top of the hill
and john showed up with every white kid
in town and i'm standing there with
[ __ ] martin perez
valentine pharaoh dominic speciale and
michael special
you know he showed up with 15 [ __ ]
kids
and they made a circle and i fought him
and he broke my nose
and i gave him a black eye and he busted
my lip he really beat me up if you want
to know the truth
and the next day we just went to school
like nothing happened and then like a
week late he comes up to me
and he goes listen what happened i feel
really bad and he shook my hand and
i took it for what it was i always knew
something was going to happen between us
one day where i'd stab him or something
i didn't say nothing and [ __ ] uh
you know what he he became my friend
like he would look out for me and
he kind of d we used to go to
we used to go
he would ask me to go steal punks with
him
that's how young we were we would go
steal uh
[ __ ] punks from the meadowlands those
things that you let on fire and
mosquitoes would go away
and he he go down there take 50 of those
things come back sell them and give me
25 bucks oh
so he felt guilty about what he had done
and i take the 25 bucks and
you know we started going to movies
together he always liked ugly chicks
and he always got me double dated and
the chick looked like a [ __ ] bus
hitter
you know and we became friends and i
used to lend them my mini bike and the
deal was if i gave my mini mic
for the day he'd let me eat italian food
in his house
and his mom cooked the best [ __ ]
meatballs and sauce and i got
and salad and just
it was a [ __ ] amazing my head would
blow up when i go to and they'd be
cutting hair in the living room because
renee the one that's in a coma would be
cutting hair on wednesdays and i'd sit
there i didn't give a [ __ ] about the
hair i would get a bowl of pasta like
rigatoni like uh you know like ziti okay
and they put sauce on it and two
meatballs and a [ __ ] big scoop of
cheese and we mix it up and then they
put parmesan on it for me and she'd make
me a big salad with italian dressing
homemade with [ __ ] hot pepper crushed
hot pepper that's a salad yeah dog they
[ __ ] freaked me out
so they were very nice to me and then i
would go they got i used to have a top
pool you know the pool above the ground
and they got a below the ground pool and
they invited me over there so i became
friends with the [ __ ] father
and the brother and the whole goddamn
family i was family
and i was when my mom died i was
supposed to move in with calmly but he
was too strict i couldn't adjust so i
moved in with the benders man and
whatever my relationship was the mother
wasn't good but the father was one of
the best men i've ever met in my life
there's not a week that goes back i
don't think about jimmy bender and the
donald cry or i don't feel bad because i
didn't see him before he died
i [ __ ] him over i didn't go to his
father's wake like a [ __ ] junkie that
i was
i was supposed to go to the wake and i
stayed up till five in the morning and
missed the [ __ ] funeral and i was too
embarrassed to call him after that
i think i did call him from prison one
time but i hung up
that he ended up dying of cancer
when i did the longest shot at the
premiere party at rascals in jersey city
and the sister the daughter and john
showed up
and we've been trying to rekindle a
relationship ever since
you know but it just uh
and if i ever fee i learned the biggest
lesson of my life then
i had no right moving in there because i
loved john but i didn't love him
that much john didn't do drugs
john and me had one hobby the movies and
eaten
and he would make me laugh you know but
john wanted more from me that i couldn't
give him as a friend because i wanted to
get i was in pain
john wanted to listen to the [ __ ]
beatles
and stay home at night and bang ugly
chicks and that wasn't for me and he was
getting [ __ ] all the time dawg since he
was 10 he was knocking out [ __ ] in
that [ __ ] apartment
you know his father was very lenient i
embarrassed his family
i say it right out i stole from his
family you know i don't feel guilty i i
feel very guilty about it
and uh i always felt guilty the day they
asked me to leave
and today i think i'm gonna i started
the process of uh
just trying to eliminate that before i
[ __ ] punch the ticket because
i just acted incorrectly man they were
one of the best families i ever met in
my life
you know at that time i used to hang out
with the benders the balzanos the
denny's the morans the
garcias i got a six or seven different
houses man because
these you know i didn't have did i
didn't have this type of family
structure in my house at that age by
that time by the time i was 12 my mother
worked every day if i wanted to see my
mother would go to a bar and she'd give
me whatever i wanted to
but i didn't want to go up there i was
as independent as could be and 12.
that's crazy at 12 i was doing laundry i
was ironing my clothes
i was shopping for myself
i was vacuuming for my mother i was
washing the windows i was cutting the
grass
i was still smoking dope and doing
illegal criminal activities
but don't get me wrong i was doing what
i was supposed to do that's why when she
died i adapted to it so easily in a way
because
i was already watching me you know
better than anybody else could watch me
was it weird that you that your mom
worked and wasn't at home during the day
for you or was that normal for north
broken because i'm trying to think of
like the 70s in the 70s both parents
worked really okay and there was a
neighborhood
group
okay
you know i hear i'm hearing more and
more of these complaints from people
that they just don't see kids that this
is the indoor generation
if you're 25 and under you're the an
indoor generation they have no
whatever outdoor that's why i push you
to go out because i learned the hard way
i learned the ease
my mother used to make me go out of the
house
she didn't know i was doing what i was
doing but she wanted me to get out of
the house
and she set something for me at the same
time she taught me how to get out and do
something
you know i i talk to people who get hurt
at work i've got a surgery now because
i'm at that age
and they tell me that the worst thing
about the whole thing is that they have
to sit at home and watch daytime
television they didn't know how bad it
really was
that you don't know how bad it really
was
i try to avoid daytime i don't try to
turn that tv on the tv comes goes on the
morning when i get on is the news and
once mercy gets up it's 289 i watched
disney i watched uh
[ __ ] elena and the other two is it is
peppa pig still big is she still no she
doesn't have that big big number pep
pig's gun
it's elena of avatar there's a new one
you know and then she's into trolls
so when i left the house she was singing
earth with the fire september and [ __ ]
and she would tell the mother to stop it
i'm singing
so it was pretty interesting but i
that's why i got this morning i got
mercy out at 9.
i was like where you guys going we're
gone that's that's in my blood you gotta
get out gotta get out your room is clean
make the bed let's go brush your teeth
we're just gonna go to the park and then
my wife met and i went to jiu jitsu
like i went there early eleven o'clock
but you gotta get your kid out of the
house and now that i watched that
stupid ben [ __ ] affleck movie which i
enjoyed because of that issue
because i still believe that i've had
parents tell me that their kids have
extreme cases of add they have impulse
what what i mean how many times have i
walked but what do you think when i left
the house
there's a million times i left the house
thinking i was going to go to church and
i ended up robbing [ __ ] a super uh
7-eleven things like that that's impulse
control
when you go out and see somebody's purse
on the floor and you [ __ ] stop what
you're doing to click the [ __ ] purse
with a 20 billion two days ago i found
the fin at 7-eleven till this day you
put your foot on it
you just walk like you [ __ ] got a bad
knee wait you didn't ask the guy behind
the counter if anyone missed it or if
they'd have lost and found oh yeah yeah
i'm gonna ask them if there's a lost and
found you know where that's gonna go
right to isis
what are you [ __ ] rethought it was
tony bennett
uh
somebody
yes
so uh
what's gonna tell you [ __ ]
today
we had a great month thank you for
listening and thank you for supporting
us
uh you know we're trying to put we're
trying to [ __ ] give you guys great
shows we're trying to give you a monthly
report we're trying to get this music
we're going for next month we got a
great month in mar a great month of
podcast in march
so uh thank you for the continued
support from the bottom of our [ __ ]
little hearts and [ __ ] we thank you
for coming to the shows and for buying
t-shirts and you know for the love that
you give me and lee
but uh today you know every day i've
been i told you guys i've been writing
every day started with a sentence a day
now i'm up to like two and a half
paragraphs and i clean up the paragraph
from the day before
whether it's good or bad i don't know
let the out of the [ __ ] take a look
at it he's probably listening right now
anyway
send him some props my main man gordon
and uh
i listen to music sometimes when i'm
just
uh outlining it
do you is it specific music no no no no
no no
i'm doing facebook i cut i get home from
jiu jitsu
i do the jiu jitsu bjj journal i write
what i learned you know to the t how i
did rolling i write down that i went on
the mat that day so it's a number for
the mat
i'm up to 2.86 this month so i didn't do
all that bad
um
uh what else did i [ __ ] do and then i
do a couple other things then i go take
a shower i eat lunch with my wife then i
go back
and i check out all the [ __ ] i did any
other emails i print when i got an email
and then the last thing i printed it was
lit lift and i put youtube on and i got
a notebook or a piece of paper and i
outlined
what i want to say that day just to blow
it through instead of sitting there like
a [ __ ] momo so it used to take me two
hours now it's taking me 45 [ __ ]
minutes
because for 35 minutes i'll outline it
and it's a 10 minute ride it's [ __ ]
unbelievable i never did it this way so
i do it that way and i'm sitting there
and i don't know what the [ __ ] i put on
i think it was uh
sweet
melissa or something by the allman
brothers and i guess sometimes youtube
rotates you have a playlist and then
they have a playlist on there they were
just playing songs they played uh they
went from the allman brothers to molly
hatchet to
uh
some other country thing and then it
went into lennox candid uh
give me back my bullets but i'm not
watching the videos i'm outlining
somebody had called i think you had
called that one time and i said hold on
for one second oh yeah all this [ __ ] was
going on
and
leonard skinner uh free bird which
you've heard a million [ __ ] time
comes up
so it's coming on and i'm hearing all
this [ __ ] and
i keep outlining i'm talking to my wife
and put the earphones back on it's up to
a partner i go let me look at this for a
second and guys
my [ __ ] tongue dropped
like it just sucked me in
i saw something that this is why i think
i was on hot ones
and i talked about my influences and i
said
that it's not listen you could say how
many comedians you like i could tell you
i really liked richard pryor i really
liked the style of the other guy the
white dude
you know i was a big lenny bruce fan you
know
but
music has really got me enthusiastic
about how they both meet like comedy and
music kind of meet somewhere
and
you know i looked at julius irving as a
child and i said wow if i could do
comedy i would do it and then it's a
weird whatever i just like taking it to
the hoop
julius irving wasn't
wasn't he was great at dunking
but he was great at taking it to the
hoop and that's why i like julia serving
because i like taking it to the hoop i
don't like going up there and
dilly-dallying with you [ __ ] i
would never do that i hate when people
go up on stage and they don't take it to
the hoop
and then they like richard pryor for the
language he used i like lenny bruce i
liked richard pryor because he brought
out that drug language and [ __ ] it
freaked people out so he let me i
allowed myself to [ __ ] take that drug
type of comedy from him but then music
influenced me and i liked the [ __ ]
style of led zeppelin like the way they
[ __ ] came out no drama no explosions
just four [ __ ] dirty guys just
playing you know but they're english
so people there was an english explosion
in the 60s you know all those bands
[ __ ] i don't even know whatever we
could go through this [ __ ] later but
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you guys know
what i'm talking about the beatles led
zeppelin so it was a kind of liking
for led zeppelin and all these english
type of bands david bowie eric clapton
list goes on but then
i'm looking at this [ __ ] let's get it
and it's a performance live from oakland
77
maybe a couple months before they died
you know
put it in the middle lead let's start it
from the middle where they
start losing their [ __ ] mind
by the hat yeah stop by that let's see
if they're losing their mind yet
all right so i'm watching this [ __ ]
video
now kick it up a little more
no no to the middle
to the middle
now i'm watching this ronnie van zandt
kick it up right here
if you can watch this video right now on
your computer turn on
uh
[Music]
whatever they are leonard skinner live
oakland
uh free bird
and i want you to watch the whole thing
and what you're gonna [ __ ] see
is yet
the six guys that are [ __ ]
tremendous musicians from the piano
player billy
to [ __ ] you know the the bass player
the savages but this is oakland
and oakland is known for [ __ ] black
i'm sitting here right now with lee and
i'm staring at three levels of [ __ ]
people in a stadium it's part of like a
summer jam obviously
but
they're all rocking
i mean i would love to be in the first
five rows it's all
women with bikini tops you can probably
smell their monkeys and armpits and [ __ ]
and their dirty feet
but yeah lennon's gonna drop it that's
great they're expected to rock
but i'm watching this and i'm like wait
a second there's nobody in those three
tiers of people which what do you think
lee how many people are we looking at
right now at least eighty thousand it's
where the it is play it's like
at the time whatever 77.
now these guys got a confederate flag up
on stage
they got poop they got the what's the
poor presence
oh the uh
mount
mount rushmore there you go they got the
four presidents cut in half two on one
side and two on the other it's a daytime
so there's no light show they got
american flags everywhere hanging on the
stage
they're [ __ ] rocking okay
if you're looking at this video
go a little more when they uh
all three of them are on stage just
going [ __ ] bananas
a little more right there right around
there
you have to see this to believe it i
like the [ __ ] what what minute mark
ellie right now we're at about 8 28
right 8 28 8 29
you think first of all the lead singer's
just walking around he just spit he's
got a heineken on the [ __ ] amp
he doesn't give a [ __ ] there's no
dancing
there's no [ __ ] around this j it's
just him he's just a redneck and he
loves just sitting back there while
these three guys
don't give a [ __ ] and again i'm looking
at these guys
you can tell they're not thinking about
nothing
they are there and to me
that is the [ __ ] heart right there
there's no resistance
they're not looking at these guys going
wait a second
where's all the cowboys at
these guys are imposing their will
that is the art league
would you be saying that if the music
wasn't so good like if they were playing
as confidently
part of the the reason why they're so
good they're confident look
the guy's jumping up and down
okay
this is oakland this is not tennessee
this is not the south
these guys are ripping this stadium up
like this would be the [ __ ] south
this is what some people would see what
i'm seeing is the art that these people
have i that they're imposing their will
this is this is
redneck music
when i was growing up in jersey and i
heard this the first time i was like are
you crazy but i listen to it some more
and i'm like wait a second these
[ __ ] got a message and then i
bought give me back my bullets and
that's what my mind almost [ __ ] blew
up
when when you first showed me this i
asked you if there were hippies because
i was looking at the video look at the
guy making out with his chick this is
when concerts were [ __ ] 15
for eight bands
but this guy's
took him back to like a micro economic
type of look
in their minds they're in a [ __ ] barn
in tennessee
rocking for their cousins
there's no explosives there's nothing
fancy
they just rocked the [ __ ] out of you
and that state of mind is the art if you
see where i'm coming from
and we've discussed it ten thousand
times but tonight i brought it
the war of art i have read this book
maybe ten times
i bought one i bought it one time and i
made my notes in here and i don't like
it it became annoying
in case it becomes somebody else's book
or they want to read it and they got to
see stupid notes or
me outlining the whole thing
but it's pretty funny if you ever get
this book it's not a hard read
at all
it's uh
what's hard is sitting down to write
and remember i was telling you guys like
what i knew like this guy just breaks it
down
and what he really talks about if you
go to a store and you pick this up
do you dream about writing the great an
american novel do you regret not
finishing your paintings
poems or screenplays do you want to
start a business or a charity
wish you could start dieting or
exercising today hope to run a marathon
someday if you've answered yes to any of
these questions
then you need the war of art
this powerful straight from the hip
examination of the internal obstacles to
success
this is what i was living through all
those years
when i started doing that stuff on
myspace and writing
somebody turned me on to this book
and i [ __ ] cried the first couple
times i read this
because this is why i've been all my
life
and this guy ended up you know this guy
is not coming on like he's some [ __ ]
big shot right big-time author he's
coming on he's telling you
what he went through
and what
the number one problem we have standing
in our way people always go you know
what jody's biggest problem is he's
standing in his own way give me an
expression all the time when people say
and this book is basically
you know hitler wanted to be an artist
at 18 he took his inheritance 700 cronin
and moved to vienna to live and study he
applied to the academy of fine arts and
later to the school of architecture ever
seen one of hitler's paintings neither
have i resistance beat him
call an overstatement but i'll say it
anyway
it was easier for hitler to start world
war ii
than it was for him to face a blank
square of canvas
holy [ __ ] when did they write this book
do you have any that's crazy okay this
is guys if you're stuck you know listen
guys i got led back in the seventh grade
i got a g d
i'm not coming on like anthony robinson
but i'll tell you what
this defined a lot of [ __ ] stupid
questions i had
you know enemy is a very good teacher
you know and it has resistance greatest
hits it defines what we don't do
we simplify it as resistance the
following is a list in no particular
order of those activities that most
commonly
elicit resistance the pursuit of any
calling in writing painting music
film dance or creative art however
marginal or unconventional the launching
of an entrepreneurial venture of
enterprise for profit or otherwise any
diet or health regimen any program of
spiritual advancement any activity whose
aim is to tighten abdominals any course
of program designed to overcome and
unwholesome habit or addiction education
of any kind and any act of political
moral or ethical courage including the
decision to change for the better some
unworthy pattern of thought or conflict
in ourselves
you know
i sit here with lee 20 [ __ ] times
and we giggle and we break his balls but
the underlying thing you know
i went through all this [ __ ] guys when i
sit here and tell you no matter what
position you're in your life right now
you get yourself out of it
if you don't believe that stop listening
stop listening i talk to people at shows
not every week
who they'll pull me aside and i'll go
you know what man
i had this [ __ ] job
and i listened and i decided to start
playing a band again
and now i have a part-time job and i
played two nights
and it's because i had the balls to take
a chance if not i would have been stuck
the rest of my life
miserable because at least i didn't give
it a try
you gotta give it a [ __ ] try it's two
thousand [ __ ] seventeen and it ain't
getting better
that's like when you're reading off that
list like the first like four of them
are one thing everyone's a dude yeah no
no this is
for [ __ ] a year i sat there and i
would try to write a book i wasted a
year on this book since i've been with
this guy gordon
and all of a sudden i read this book
again before i shot the special okay
before i even started writing the
special i read this book
and i got my dick card and then i read
it again before the surgery i read it on
days i don't want to go to jiu jitsu
i read it on days i don't want to go to
a meeting
i'll just pull it out i have two two
copies of this
i got in the travel
bag because guys it's
listen
it's that easy to [ __ ] slip
it's that easy to slip anymore you guys
know what i'm [ __ ] talking about
i talked to jram i talked to a bunch of
[ __ ] guys that are having problems
j i hope you're not mad at me no i got
nothing but love to you let me give you
some shout outs real quick and we'll
continue this conversation yeah we're
going to cover a couple books this month
i got the guy
who was the undercover cop on the iceman
we're going to cover a book by anthony
bruno called the iceman
i'm going to order it tonight from
amazon
uh when steve came on that's always a
great idea like a book club
guys let me tell you something if you're
stuck you want to get off an addiction
your heart broke and get yourself a
couple of books get a biography of
somebody you admire you know and if
you're broke go online they got cheap
books online so what if the back page is
ripped
it's the you know
do you have a favorite fiction author or
do you not read a lot of fiction i don't
know what fictional non-fiction is you
know fiction's like made-up stories
you know i like biographies yeah i like
biographies too you know i like the one
about the guy who killed grebo i don't
know what that is american
whatever renegade i like
books like this the war of art anything
that can help me
i've told you the books that changed my
[ __ ] life you ready right the war of
art got it
the art of war
the other one by shinzo that had like
two things in there i [ __ ] applied to
all the time
but the number one book that has helped
me the most in my whole life was a book
i bought in 1987 called telephone sales
in the 80s
that was the greatest book i ever read
in my life
it was my bible it's because who i'm
here today
it really was that great of a book and
i've read it right anthony i went to two
anthony robbins seminars
i've done a lot of that [ __ ] guys i'm
not gonna sit here and tell you i went
to a lot of that [ __ ] because i thought
it was crazy
i thought i was [ __ ] crazy
you know six or seven years after my mom
died you could have sold me a [ __ ]
any religion if scientology would have
got my hand on me right now i would have
been the captain of the ship speaking of
that just have you seen that big
scientology building oh they're back in
the valley happening oh yeah we'll go
[ __ ] with them oh my god let's go [ __ ]
with them let's go get on the guy got me
to tell them we suck dick
[ __ ] tell him we meant to vault on an
orgy one time you're sucking a penguin's
dick the whole thing yeah they're
bringing it back they used to sponsor
the
the
the food trucks
oh no on thursday so you go in there and
get a sandwich next you know you got a
[ __ ] johnny scientologist
asking if you want to take an iq test so
i stopped going i wanted my daughter
when they embarrassed the [ __ ] out of me
paris is the [ __ ] out of me you don't
need to bother me let me get some shout
outs real quick before i forget did i
read them yet no reese coke spoon jeff
collins my main man matt balthazar
another soldier nick
buffalusios i love you you [ __ ] greek
[ __ ] tell these [ __ ]
malacca chuck madden alex castino
anthony guzzo ookie spooky always and
the [ __ ] philly godfather and
jason silva
i uh announced that i'm gonna do
atlantic city
july 29th
we got my goobies in baltimore march
16th
and we got levity live and [ __ ]
nayak so i'm having a good time in
[ __ ] march we got norton coming on we
got we got people coming on in march
they're gonna blow your [ __ ] socks up
but anyway back
the telemarketing in the 80s rocked my
world
it taught me all about sales broke it
down to me how to sell on the phone
which i fell in love with
there's days i dream about waking up and
going to sell [ __ ] on the phone and then
i'll just call agents and harass them
and call managers and harassment trying
to sell them on different ideas and [ __ ]
do you still have your copy of that book
nah i lost it and i thought i thought
that you had
looked it up and they changed it to
telemarketing in the 90s then
telemarketing i mean check
that was the most that book put me over
the top you know like other books cujo
put me over the top that i probably read
the godfather when it came out
i was 10.
i read the [ __ ] godfather when i was
10.
for fun or for school
for fun jesus
look before drugs i was a [ __ ] nerd
guy
i read books and i pictured and i
[ __ ] had a telescope you know
i was looking for [ __ ] martians and
[ __ ] not really but i was like i like to
look at stars at night and uh
you're gonna find the [ __ ] i'm trying
to run the room like a [ __ ]
i'm saying if they have i have a look
back at the golden age successful
telephone selling in the 90s
okay that's the one it's a blue cover
with a phone call on it let's see
uh yeah who the [ __ ] do you think you're
dealing with well he didn't update it
for two thousand it's a different game
out there now
yeah that book changed my [ __ ] life
there were so many books that i used to
before i got locked up
i read every book on law i read books on
lawyers
you gotta read guys if you get stuck in
your life
and your mind name right get yourself a
couple books and you know what don't
[ __ ] cry to me it costs nothing to
get a library card
you know the most interesting thing
somebody came up to me this week and a
good a guy that's come to shows from
denver he came to like two or three
shows with his wife cool [ __ ]
always brings me a gift i'm sorry i
forget his name i mean a lot of people
on the road at the end of two shows you
stoned but he told me that he started
writing his goals then
and that things changed
that's amazing
dog
[ __ ] [ __ ] changes at the speed of
lightning i don't want to freak you out
but they have successful telephone
selling in the 80s on ebay for 3.99
all right i'll go home and get it
tonight
that's how strong that book is that book
taught me more
because it was more of a psychology
approach to it instead of a gorilla
approach to it like i read every book on
sales there was
you know
when i got into [ __ ] i got into [ __ ]
guys even if i was doing blow that's
what i would do i do blow and read
that's the best time to [ __ ] read
when you do blow
oh my god when i was on the road from
when i was on the road from 98
to 2003 i probably read
i would go to that barnes and nobles in
every city
and i'd buy books that i'd give away i'd
read them but ninety percent of those
books i'd read when i was coked up
to the gills
is that maybe one of your retention
wasn't good
no my retention would be great because i
was coked up the adderall was in full
effect oh wow so i would i would [ __ ]
do a show and plan on going back to the
room with a grandma blow
and a six pack of beer and i would just
sit there and [ __ ] read whatever
what did you ever turn a girl away
because you wanted to read a book or
going back and forth anybody who turns a
girl away before because of a book needs
a beat
needs for somebody to take him in an
alley and say what's wrong with you i
want to go home and read a book what are
you [ __ ] crazy
i don't know maybe invaluable no no no i
listen there was no women i could lie to
you at this time it was some nights i
would do blow read a book and then get
all horned up and go out
and try to be evil but who am i gonna
pick up i wouldn't pick up nobody have
you ever like
cause i see you just picking up random
books sometimes like did you ever pick
up one of those like uh cbs fantasy
erotic novels and read those no you
would never read that no no no no
my mom read novellas okay
and one read
novellas growing up
and when i would get really bored i
would go in there and try to read the
books in spanish so are they like
legitimate like the soap operas but just
written out yeah but juan read more like
uh cowboy [ __ ]
and my mother read more like
romance but i never even saw those again
i don't even know before she got him to
be honest
as a kid i read a lot of readers digest
oh yeah i really liked reader's digest
one of the best articles i ever read
in reader's digest was about jim valvano
that's why i first read all that [ __ ]
stuff like juicy it was really good in
there
i don't read magazines very seldom do i
read magazines i'm a book guy now
and it's a shame but i don't have the
time to read more books
but i have to be a dad and i gotta pay
attention to the podcast you gotta do a
lot of stuff but i'm always reading
[ __ ] something
again lolingus i love you but you [ __ ]
you cursed me
because now i gotta read eight thousand
pages about jimmy page by the time i
read that book i'll be back into [ __ ]
stabbing satanists and you know chasing
them in the park and [ __ ]
what about books on tape because i know
i don't know if you do like the ipod but
i can see you all that driving just
getting a bunch of books on tape
and listening to books or not really i
love to tell you that i wouldn't like it
but i also never tried it oh really so
i'd be bullshitting yeah yeah i've never
tried it i never my wife does it no my
wife has the thing that she still reads
you know man
i like to hold on to some things
it's definitely different and i really
like when i get a book and i open it the
read of the book and like the covers
when you take the cover off and you see
what the book like
looks like you know
i like all that [ __ ]
it's still it's like these albums you
know sometimes we end the podcast and we
at least sit here for an hour when i
look at the albums i miss that
i miss that part of my life just
touching those covers and [ __ ]
i'm a nostalgic it's not like i'm a
collector but
like there's a lot of books i read and i
take right when i go to the
you know the place up the corner where
you give away books and clothes goodwill
goodwill i take all the books i try to
there's a lot of books i like to keep
because maybe i say to myself i'm going
to read it again
and i'll never [ __ ] read them
i read this book once that freaked me
out it's i think about it sometimes i
have no idea what it's called
i don't even think i still have it
but it was this guy
who
sent
somebody a jail cell
and had them build it in his base like
build him a cell and he like made
himself be put in jail for some [ __ ] for
some reason he wouldn't tell the guy why
he did it
but it's just
i don't know like this it's weird wrong
book affects you for a long time
do you remember the author or anything
no i could look it up i might even still
have it but it was just
where did you get the book from i was uh
i walked into a bookstore one day who
gives you this weird shitley no i i
walked into a bookstore one day and you
know what but i didn't even walk in it
was i wanted like those carts that was
like outside and i just looked at it it
looked interesting i think i think it
might have been like the last book that
i actually ever read how long ago was
that
six years something like that
but you read a lot online you do a lot
of investigative [ __ ]
when i talk to you about microphones
you go online and you you [ __ ] you
know you love to
god forbid you don't yelp a [ __ ]
hot dog stand somewhere
oh well we're gonna go here let's yelp
the food on the corner there's a hot dog
stand down there yeah that that's that's
really sad that that's the extent of my
reading
reviews but it's uh
i think that one of the things that
really kept me together
as [ __ ] up when i was burglarizing and
doing drugs that i was taking classes
guys
jesus christ
what possessed me to stay
and i would pay out of pocket oh it's
not till i got to see you bold and i got
the continuing education there
that they would start throwing me loans
in those days but not no not loans
grants what am i saying there was no
loans
grants
once i got a certain amount of credits
they said you can apply for grants so i
started applying for the latino grants
and these cuban grants i was picking up
two to three hundred dollars there
there's a whole world of grants you
don't really know about and like i said
i had my man manny in boulder
he was the man with the plan for the
small hundred he got you like a thousand
dollars in grants jesus christ yeah the
ten percent
yeah i i have no i
i got out of school as quick as i could
i i took summer classes when i was
interning out here so i could graduate a
semester early
and if you get out of prison
you could look into
because there's some campuses that'll
tell you that'll allow you
but they're really blowing smoke up your
ass they'll take your application but
they're not going to give you a shot i'm
not gonna lie to you about that but
there's some colleges that don't give a
[ __ ] and they just specialize in that
that they get your aid and everything
don't even get your money for housing
and [ __ ] if you get locked up and i'm
not talking about a skill i'm talking
about going back to college
getting your ged you get your ged
they'll take you back in the [ __ ]
college dog
if i did it you could [ __ ] do it
just walk in there like you own the spot
and tell them the story i had to quit
because i was on drugs i had to quit
because i went to jail i had to quit
because i knocked up a woman tell them
the [ __ ] truth on your application
and say you're trying to get your life
together you think this would be a great
ending to a great story you go back to
[ __ ] school
don't give a [ __ ] what they tell you i
really [ __ ] don't
there's one school out there and
especially now that campuses are online
are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah you could do it from home there was
a uh someone who was 40 years old in
paul's law school class
and he was doing it online no he was
doing it he was going to actual class
but he was 40. so you can do it whenever
dawg i
i don't know what i would do if i could
do it
if i had the opportunity to go two
nights a week like i'd have to give up
the podcast but see like that's like
and i know you're very busy but you have
the opportunity you could apply right
now
like
listen lee in anybody's world you have
the opportunity to do whatever the [ __ ]
you want
but
the longness in the tooth
and uh
i want to be there for my daughter just
in case
is always looming over my [ __ ] head
i've worked it out with myself to be out
of town six days a month
that's
my wife is telling me that she's asking
about me more when i go out of town
you know when i called sunday she goes
he already has the budget two times
and i said please keep her there
before the party starts let me see it
and everything was fine this morning
she was pretty happy and went to the
park i got to pay attention to italy
i [ __ ] up once before this one
i gotta pay attention to so it's a big
chunk
even if i just sit there with her and
play the moana dolls with her
it's the world to her and she'll
remember forever
you know but i mean pretty soon
she's gonna be going to school
and then [ __ ] yeah is she really next
year jesus
that's it
that's it it's gonna make up my mind
and the beauty of it is if we stay where
we're at we could walk into school every
day and walk back home and be on my
[ __ ] quarter tonight and do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do
am i petrified
i'm like any parent i'm petrified for
her but i also think she'll do great
i think she'll do great i really believe
in her
you know
what are you what are you petrified of
her getting hurt in any way
and she's a little tank but she's still
a little girl you know
i enjoy my time at home i enjoy my time
with them
it's something that i have to do as a
personal choice lee it's something i
made a big mistake once before
and even though we weren't i could tell
you a thousand stories how
it wasn't gonna last in the beginning it
was a bad situation yeah maybe that's
true too
but i knew i didn't put the full effort
into it and i don't want the same to
happen again i like comedy i like going
out there but i can't go out there i
feel the difference when i take three
planes in a row
compared to two planes in a row you know
i mean that's it the comedy is the
[ __ ] most enjoyable thing i've ever
done in my life
let's face it it's the plane ride
waiting at the airport for your luggage
you know you're supposed to land at nine
you landed a quarter to nine but the
plane coast still [ __ ] 9 45.
you should i'd rather fly around so i
could watch the rest of the [ __ ]
movie instead of sitting here you know
saying like that's what it's hectic
every time you go up and every time you
go down it takes a toll on your system
you want to rest in between you want to
be hydrated i drink like 22 bottles of
water when i'm on those planes
yeah you go to the bathroom a lot oh i
go because i stretch my legs
i do leg raises i move my neck i rotate
my shoulders you know i've been doing it
so i'm prepared for it you know
but at the same time i got to be a
father i got to be a husband i'm going
on a date with my wife friday night
you know i got to do these things last
week when i was here we went to the
family dance
if i don't do this late
who is who is i i i can't do it i'll
lose them and over what
i was very lucky i had but i had both
parents home my dad worked nights a lot
but he was home during the day very
important yeah it's huge it's very
[ __ ] important and it's important to
me
again
i see in today's society and i know for
a fact parents gotta work jack
parents gotta [ __ ] work parents got
to work today both of them both them to
make it happen
it cost you from a to z i look at the
[ __ ] bills for her you got to work
jack
you got to work just just even the cover
basic like housing and food is expensive
now it's i figured it out like a month
ago without the calculator by the way
and my jaw dropped and the sneakers for
her and
you know i looked at thank god
that got me and my wife ain't got homes
you know i we have a simple dinner
schedule friday we go to mcdonald's
it's what she likes
some fridays i
get chicken nuggets with her you're not
done two fries a week yeah excuse me
you're not home two fridays a month yeah
so the two fridays i'm home we pick her
up and she wants to go to mcdonald's we
get a the gift box
and i'm [ __ ]
uh sunday we go to mama maria's where
it's forty dollars for all three of us
you know me and my wife don't go
overboard we cooked during the week my
wife made a beautiful piece of [ __ ]
uh uh
uh whatever tonight not salmon but the
other one halibut right
with some corn you know i stay in i mean
the main concern
is the child and her future you know i'm
thinking about different things now
they offered me some pretty neat stuff
on the road they offered me some
theaters on the road oh yeah i'll be
talking about it more you know
like i said i'm trying to write i'm
trying to put together a whole new
[ __ ] situation here
uh i'm on for 420 with d agastino
and uh
felicia michaels for oxnard
i'm trying to get my main man matt
fultron with me at levity live
april 20 uh whatever whenever i'm up
there at the end of the month
uh
theo vaughn was in denver this week and
thank you very much for the people
from the church that went and supported
theo vaughn he he really did great he
was at the other club and i got him into
the comedy works and rick curran showed
up and had a great time with him so if
you went
to see theo vaughn and also i want to
thank you guys for supporting the comics
that come on the church i'm hearing
great [ __ ] things from kate quigley
in fact some kids sent me something from
vegas yeah you guys go out and see greg
fitzsimmons and we listen
it's a beautiful [ __ ] thing comedy
everybody was [ __ ] sold out this
weekend so
if you're into comedy [ __ ] thank you
from the bottom of my heart man
a little [ __ ] over here my nutsack it's
not really the nutsack it's above the
[ __ ] thing what are you looking at me
all week i'm sorry i apologize so yeah
we got a this book will really help you
oh i can't i'm going to order it now no
i'll let you i want you to read it and
in a week give me what you thought okay
this is really going to help you lee
this is going to narrow you down you
know it gets a little weird at some
points
just read through it it's
i want you to read about resistance i
want you to really
get into what the [ __ ] resistance is
resistance is invisible and it once you
read that and you understand where you
how your mind works
you know when it broke it down like i
said when i read the anthony robbins
thing
a lot of that made sense
but a lot of it was repetitive and
either it's gonna stick or it's not and
thirty percent of the time it don't
stick this [ __ ]
sticks if you look at the right on
writing
sticks
this [ __ ] sticks with you and this is
you know man i get a thousand [ __ ]
emails a day thank you
dante gazzini always sends emails i read
his letters but i got a lot of emails
from people on different gmail accounts
and [ __ ]
and people are stuck
people are [ __ ] stuck now again
bro get a notebook
start writing it down you want to get
off those pills you want to get off that
heroin you want to get off the blow it
took me a year of writing how much i
hated [ __ ] life
for me to finally get off the powder and
i know that
20 of it was the [ __ ] i was writing in
that notebook i looked at that notebook
three years later
and i not just threw it away a lot of
notebooks you just throw away okay
i ripped the covers off it and i cut
each page with scissors
and such tiny things because i never
wanted anyone to ever read what i went
through that year before i quit cocaine
the things that were on that paper
were
truth
a lot of truth which isn't pretty
that's like that's really dark dude like
like
like you went like you made you cut
every page every january i would start
every january one i would get two
notebooks because i know i would go
through two notebooks and i would name
them that year okay and in 2007 the year
i got off blow
i threw that notebook away when i moved
to the valley which was 2009
and when i was like maybe i'll keep this
maybe i'll keep this who knows
and when i started reading it i said
not only do i not want to keep this i
don't want to see this again because
this was
a per if somebody read this just by
reading this
they give this to the authorities and
make them come get me just to do a
like they'd probably take my shoelaces
and [ __ ] put me in a black cell i
swear they got 50 150 or whatever that
the [ __ ] i was writing that those last
eight months before i
that summer when i was doing heroin
oh the [ __ ] i would write at night when
i was doing heroin
was so sad
was just my bit of guts of what i
thought about myself
why i was doing the drug you know and
then it got goofier and goofier i was
gonna
stop snorting coke by doing the heroin
and then when i and then there was that
[ __ ] weekend in november and then if
you look at the week before i quit coke
instead of writing a page and a half i
was writing like four pages this is how
you remember everything
this is crazy
i never knew you did all this you have
to write when you wake up in the morning
and then midday you have to finish the
other side of the page and explain how
your day went what your expectations
were
what you didn't really do if you really
stick to this
and you keep three years at a time and
you look back and you [ __ ] will throw
it away
unless you're just like gambling and
making millions or you're in the stock
market but to see the guts what you were
writing when you were struggling
is something that's
i would never publish it
even now i look like i look at
in july i'll look at next last year's
how honest are you in them like is it
hard to be brutally honest do you lie to
yourself sometimes no no no no no no no
no i'm like you know
they're not memoirs and that's not a
diary with a lock on it
you know what i'm saying remember 20
years people i'm right in my diary every
day and then everybody would steal your
[ __ ] diary and you crack and people
would steal your diary you'd be in there
talking about how you like [ __ ] uh
candy canes or something no this is
what i wake up in the morning
my morning writing is about
when i wake up in the morning if i'm
angry about something i write it out
and why i should be angered and how i
would resolve the situation early in the
morning you ever wake up angry lisa yes
this is what you do oh my god
and it's a lot better if you smoke a
joint
this morning i didn't wake up angry
i woke up really rested
and when i started writing this morning
i went on fire because
i don't know why once i saw mercy and i
started telling my wife i drank some
coffee and i was going [ __ ] bananas
but um
i've been sticking to my writing plan
six days a week two paragraphs a day
i've been sticking to it man
on its only
it just pops up it's the weirdest thing
it just pops up now
it took me four years of [ __ ] writing
to get to this
and if you read the war of art it that's
what it tells you what do you mean is
pops up so make sure you sit down and
write every day it took me four years
now now for some reason
boom next thing you know i got one
paragraph down next thing you know i'm
blending the two paragraphs together
next thing you know i add a third one
next thing i look at the clock it's ten
to five let me add my sentences for
tomorrow let me start the outline for
tomorrow and boom i close the computer
i'm done for the [ __ ] day
and the next day i have my day
proportioned so i know exactly when i'm
gonna hit that [ __ ] day
it's really weird how it doesn't become
an addiction but it becomes an automatic
response now
just because i read that stupid war of
art because i wasn't sitting down that
book forced me to sit down stop [ __ ]
yourself the only way you're going to
learn to write is by writing the only
way you're going to write your goals is
by writing your goals every day
so you find the niche in your day
and you write at that niche and also you
get like i wouldn't write my book in the
morning when i wake up my head's too
[ __ ] up there's no way so in the
morning i write jokes
that's when my head's [ __ ] up that's
how i want to write a joke
when it's not really me it's somebody
else that woke up after 22 000
milligrams of edibles and an anxiety
pill and [ __ ] joints and
i swang a bat and a protein powder but
you're not fighting yourself and trying
to write it at not at 10 pm no i'm not
chasing the goat no more no no no no no
i'm not pulling the weight watches while
i'm eating fruit at night
to beat the [ __ ] points you know i'm
saying none of that [ __ ] that's
i feel like i'm going to get really
pissed off with myself when i read this
book yes this the the time i read it a
couple weeks ago i thought a lot about
you when i read this book
because we all have a we're lacking
something the reason why we're not where
we are
is because we're lacking a certain
element in our lives and i'm no better
than you guys this is why i read this
[ __ ] i don't read this [ __ ] because i'm
king for root and i'm i'm the smart i
must fight cool i'm down whatever that
[ __ ] is what are you fight coin alum
whatever when you're the smartest person
in the school ah five beta cap is one
yeah
kumari
that told me a lot about you you [ __ ]
i would tell ya but uh i'm excited to
read it i'm excited to see
when do you think i'll make some changes
immediately and in the way i remember
he'll be a little guilty i think you'll
get a pad and read through some stuff
again
i think that uh should i take notes or
do you think i should just read them
first absolutely take notes okay you're
gonna see a lot of [ __ ] in there you
know jesus [ __ ] christ
there's one chapter where he tells you
that
sometimes you have to be a little angry
you know you know some people uh the
great bobby slayton yesterday wrote
that denzel washington was an [ __ ]
that you know
uh uh what's the name of the host
jimmy kimmel jimmy kimmel was hilarious
and denzel didn't like you know what man
that
between kids and men
there's some people ain't got time to
[ __ ] giggle all right
you want to say something funny and
knock me out of the park knock me out of
the park but if you want me to hear sit
here fake giggle i'm not gonna [ __ ]
fake giggle i don't even want to [ __ ]
be here you know what i'm saying
and that's what he talks about you have
to have a little bit
of that anger he describes his whole
writing career and all this [ __ ] he went
through
i think one of my biggest problems is
being assertive not being assertive
enough
and that's i think that's something i
have to fix again i don't think
you have any mental problems i think you
have the problems that a 28 year old has
that's sick and tired of getting kicked
in the teeth
you're striving for ideas
you come up with 10 ideas a day you have
100 ideas a week
and you start none of them
right exactly and you know
we've listened you're not you're not a
failure by no means that means your guts
that means nothing you're going to have
bad ideas
20 times i'd really really think and i
applaud you
i've been watching you for five years
and i see what you want to do when i see
what you want to want to do and you
can't find okay and you mentioned to me
you always thought and you want to be a
professional gambler not something your
mom's going to be proud of i mean she
can handle the podcast for two more
years
but if she finds out about the
professional
gambling oh yeah we discussed different
types of gambling
we discussed that there's a way to
gamble and a way to [ __ ] just throw
away your money you might as well every
time you see somebody give them 200 and
the thing that you said to me a couple
weeks ago and that that has turned
exactly true was that you're not going
to get better at it doing it once every
six months
and i in my head i don't i i talked
about how
the podcast has been doing great i'm
making i'm doing great now i'm doing a
lot better than it was a couple years
ago you cut a lot of waste okay i
haven't had cable in two years no no but
you cut a lot of the podcasts you were
doing yeah you weren't getting nowhere
so you're more refreshed more you know i
get hit up
a new company hit me up and see if they
want to i want to go in business with
them if you and i had a different
concept for a podcast and i'm like i'm
very happy with the church i'm very
happy with looking at def leppard on the
wall
i'm very happy about [ __ ] playing
music with you i don't think i should
start another [ __ ] podcast i'm very
happy with doing two podcasts a week
and that's the way it [ __ ] goes you
know what i'm saying
it's just crazy yeah read that book
and next monday we'll talk about the
next wednesday when chris herron calls
on the show next march 8th the guy had a
30 30 about addiction
if you have an addiction right now
you better watch this [ __ ] chris
herron 30 for 30. i know it's on
espn.com or something they gotta have it
on there on that 30 for 30 or when it's
on youtube
before next wednesday make sure you
watch the chris herron one this guy was
a bad [ __ ] ass
white basketball player i mean larry
bird type [ __ ]
that smoked his [ __ ] fingers you know
the same story you've heard 20 000 times
but what he's doing now i admire these
guys these guys that go clean listen
yeah i don't do the [ __ ] craziness no
more
i'll eat one of those larry pills from
time to time i'll smoke a little
edible
but god i knock on wood every [ __ ]
day that i'm not putting that white [ __ ]
in my nose or
eating butter booms and anxiety pills
and chase no no no no no no and it all
starts with this book guys
the war of art by stephen pressfield i
don't care
if you're [ __ ] drinking battery acid
read this book for me all right
and you'll be [ __ ] tweeting me in a
year going joey i'm not doing that [ __ ]
no more because of this stupid [ __ ]
book how many pages is it like
and again guys i don't even know who
stephen pressfield is i never met him
rogan had him on the podcast two of the
great great podcast
guy you know he wrote his experiences
and how you can become a better [ __ ]
and whatever but what
stops us from going
to where we're trying to get what to say
it cost 162 pages and it costs
12.95 18.95 if you're in canada 12.95 to
change your whole life i don't make a
dime on this guys
i just i'm you know i'm not sick and
tired i'm uh really concerned of all the
emails i get
with people not knowing their next move
or what's stopping them this is it
this is it
to [ __ ] me what the [ __ ] lee
so yeah
i'm not doing dick this week i'm doing
this show thursday at the store
tomorrow night
i think i'm going to go to a laker game
for the first time in [ __ ] six years
somebody invited me and it's time i get
out of the house
like i said guys you know how social
[ __ ] awkward i am
but tomorrow night i'm gonna do
something that i haven't done in years
i'm gonna go to a basketball game
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't believe i put
myself in this situation i'm gonna meet
downtown at six o'clock
so i'm gonna uber league are you gonna
uber me a [ __ ] thing
i tried to call my man he never hit me
back i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on that armenian's always on point and
[ __ ]
and uh
that's it man
let me talk to you people about
something very very important that i
opened up my underwear the other day i
opened up my underwear drawer
and there was one pair of blue
shorts like blue gym shorts as you would
call them
and everything else
was me on these i couldn't believe
that there wasn't a pair of white
underwear no more it was all me undie
whatever the big size is
and i got red ones they sent me the
valentine's day one i got [ __ ]
christmas ones i got to give lee a
couple i always forget and i put them on
i don't want to give lee hughes done the
way i appreciate that
but i gotta tell you something the more
more i wear those things the more and
more i like them i wouldn't even take
underwear on the road with me i take to
repair me undies and i only wear like
two of them i wear one like one day and
a half at the gym because ball sweats
boss right who gives a [ __ ] when you're
on the road
but i'll tell you what i like about them
i like
that i don't feel like i have something
on and that's the most important thing
about me on these all right
what is it with me undies
first of all they're seriously soft they
feel good and the undies is delivered
right to your door me undies are
designed in la and made from
substantially sourced micro modal a
fabric three times softer than cotton
beyond these softer than soft luxurious
underwears come an ever-changing
selection of classic colors
bold shades and adventurous patterns so
you can tailor your undies to your own
personal style you open up my drawer and
it looks like a rainbow of colors i got
blue underwear i got red underwear i got
underwear with hearts on them i got blue
underwear with snakes i got underwear
and guess what i like every [ __ ] pair
of them all right and guess what else
you can save time and money each month
with a monthly subscription all right
and if you're not ready for subscription
that's okay you can still save that's
because meundies is offering you 20 off
your first pair just use your special
url
meundies.com
joey and get 20 off your first pair
uncle joey never [ __ ] you these are
the pair underwear you've been going for
right so go ahead revamp your underwear
withdrawal you deserve it you want good
underwear you got to [ __ ] pay the
piper and these underwear are worth
every single [ __ ] dime i love them to
death they keep my nuts off they're
tight i don't even think i got them on
and everything's beautiful all right
once again revamp your underwear draw
once again meundies.com
joey again meundies.com
joey trust me get those for father's day
for your grandfather his balls will be
comfortable father's day is coming
mother's day is coming me undies is for
you go to meondys.com
slash joey and get 20 off your first
order or just subscribe all right number
two every time i come in here i look at
that watch lee has and i go lee is a bad
[ __ ]
lee talk to me about this watch you
still love it for that i love it
first of all i mean you've had it for i
don't know since christmas yeah at least
no problems
no no problems it's still running great
it's i really like the design it's
really lightweight like you said about
the me undies it doesn't i've had a lot
of bigger watches that feel really
clunky and you're when you're it hurts
your wrist after a while and so you
don't wear them this is really
comfortable and it's uh it it's just i
love it let me talk to you about it mvmt
watches all right pronounce the movement
was founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank right this is
what i've been telling you for years
right you want to go to a chinese
restaurant they got the lunch special
5.95 and you got a diet soda that's
that's breaking the right that's a
beautiful deal the watchmaker's goal is
to change the very the way consumers
think about fashion by offering high
quality minimalistic products at
revolutionary prices with over 1 million
watch watches sold to customers in 160
countries around the world
mbmt watches has solidified itself as
one of the world's fastest growing watch
companies all right listen you know how
we started this podcast
it started five years ago we were
getting what 3 000 downloads nobody
wanted to talk to us nobody invited us
nothing and now we rock and roll with
the best of them all right that's the
same way they did with this watch
company
movement watches start at 95
at a department store the same watch
you're looking at four to five hundred
bucks movement figured out that by
selling online they were able to cut out
the middleman like everybody's doing now
and the retail market providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construction style minimalism over 1
million watches sold in 160 countries
i'm going to tell you what i'm going to
do get 15 off today mbmt with free
shipping and free returns by going to
mvmtwatches.com
church break it down lee c-h-u-r-c-h
these watches are really having a nice
clean design i'm telling you lee
has been getting compliments i see how
he is around the [ __ ] it's a badass
watch it looks good on him now it's time
to step up your watch game go to
mvmtwatches.com
church listen to me again father's day
is coming go to
mvmtwatches.com slash church she's going
to love it all right saint patty's
coming you know you want to give your
husband or your wife a watch this is the
watch for you mbmt
dot com slash church mvmtwatches.com
mbmtwatches.com
all right we'll be back wednesday
you know i love you [ __ ] with
all my heart don't forget mcgoobies
baltimore
march 16th the day before st patty's and
then you got levity live
the last week of the month all right
guys i love you we'll be back on
wednesday ready to [ __ ] rock stay
blackish
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fans
[Music]
you